the fine linen is like touching the soul of
water
[Music]
nothing deeper than the soul of
water does not choose a fiber that
sleeps in the dark and becomes theirs
on the fine linen
[Music]
holy flower
I am clear god and  it is said about me that
I am a technical master I
learned this art from my grandmother
my grandmother was an excellent teacher at
12 I entered a loom and
a world of class opened up and I shot
we closed the  doors to that because
we do not realize that people today
are cooked by images because they take them
in shells because they try to do it myself
I thought of avoiding all this
in the diving center we can have a
maximum supply of 300 g of
crude which becomes 30 grams of  punished
that they become 21 meters of retouching thread
to make a rectangle of five by 12
of fine fabric spun one micron
it took five years
and of course it weighs a gram leg
later the fine linen cannot be bought
must sell whoever buys fine linen is
favoring poaching fine linen
cannot be bought you can have as a gift
the thread of the discourse of environmental protection
[Music]
I have chosen to love through a thread
that is not
[Music]